metagenomic data analysis
a field to unravel the microbial
Community come let's explore together
the Limitless potential of melodynamic
data analysis through our comprehensive
training program designed for begnore's
intermediate Learners and advanced
practitioners so whether you are
starting your journey or seeking to
expand your expertise this program
equips you with the skills and the
knowledge to excel in this Dynamic field
let's first discuss how the field
metagenomics came into existence in the
1800s the link between diseases and
microorganisms was established shedding
light on isolated bacteria functions and
today we understand that the human
microbiome consists of structured
communities forming biofilms with
complex interactions aiding ecological
stability advances in metagenomics
enables the study of vast majority of
uncultivable microorganisms within their
natural environments this program will
cover bioinformatics analysis of
metagenomic sequencing data which
includes genomic sequencing Technologies
data utilization analysis tools and also
real world applications
since 1900s microbiome Studies have made
significant progress notably through
initiatives like the human microbiome
project enabled by metagenomic
sequencing advances allowing
characterization of microbiota in
various human organs presenting
opportunities and challenges in
identifying their roles in organ health
and disease in this program we will
learn about the different types of
metagenom sequencing techniques to
different types of data that is
generated such as otu sequences that are
annotated by mapping onto a reference
database such as the ribosomal database
project or green genes or the silver
database such databases contain
taxonomic information for the domains of
bacteria Archaea and Eukarya based
primarily on phylogenese for small
subunit rrnas which include 16s for
prokaryotes and 18s for Eukarya based on
the mapping of specific regions
Amplified from the 16s RNA Gene is the
small subunit of bacterial ribosome
otus can be assigned to belong to a
taxonomy class of bacteria yielding a
proportionate view of the community each
Community can then be studied by
comparing with others or between similar
communities in different conditions or
individuals such analysis includes an
in-depth understanding of data
preparation reference databases and
analytical approaches to answer specific
questions based on solid evidence
importantly sequencing data represents
only one type of microbial omics with
many more becoming increasingly
available
many questions about the role of
microbiome members and communities are
now being answered using Next Generation
sequencing genomic data as well as mass
spectroscopy approaches for proteomics
and metabolomics indeed the next phase
of microbiome research lies in the
ability to integrate multiomic data sets
that combine Next Generation sequencing
Mass Spec and structural data with
phenotypic information about overall
changes in the community and their
environment in the program we will go
through three different pipelines the
first one is taxonomy classification and
then we have darado pipeline that the
noises and corrects arrows in amplicon
sequence data providing high resolution
error-free sequence variance as output
next we will also learn about the Kanto
pipeline which analyzes and processes
microbial Community data offering
diverse outputs like taxonomic
assignments diversity Matrix and
visualizations
behind many of the methods are scripts
written in popular coding languages such
as R and python these are also explained
in tutorials that you will have an
access to through the program which
includes beginner tutorials on data
importing preparation for analysis and
standard visualization of process data
taking you to an advanced level of
understanding more specialized packages
with publication ready outputs will also
be covered in more advanced lessons we
will also learn about the basics of
functional metagenomics that explores
the genetic potential and metabolic
activities of microbial communities in a
given environment so what kind of
projects can we studied using
metagenomic sequencing there are many
applications that includes skin
conditions food sensitivity of the gut
autoimmune disorders cancer antibiotic
resistance drug resistance and even
ecological studies in this program we
will learn to find and analyze data from
such repositories as the human
microbiome project which includes a data
set called the American gut the citizen
science project has a lot to offer for
those interested in basic microbial
composition of different types of
samples from healthy and mildly sick
individuals not only this there's a lot
to learn through different projects
we'll meet you in the program thank you